hey man how's it going good how's gonna  with you  good how's it going with you oh my gosh  what the hell was that Zach you asked  them how's it going he said good he asks  you how's it going you said good then  you said how's it going again yes them  twice do you even think before you talk  now he totally knows that you weren't  listening the whole time and you were  just going through the motions look Zach  I know it's a Wednesday we all go  through the motions but get your act  together man hopefully he didn't notice  but guess what everybody in the world  probably noticed how dumb you are Zach  honestly I'm embarrassed to be your  conscience right now you suck you should  just quit your job Zach move away you  notice her friends you don't know their  family and I'll deserve girls just just  get out of here what are you doing  you're worthless I'm good man oh good oh  happy belated birthday by the way uh you  too man  [Music]